Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Oh, ich glaube, ich muss noch was zu trinken holen.
Aber vorhin muss ich ein bisschen Melone futtern.
Weil ich war gerade im Wald rennen.
Da verbraucht man ordentlich Flüssigkeit.
Was geht Eats mit KI? Wasser holen?
Das wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Ich putte gerade mal meine Melone hier fertig.
Es sind mehrere Server, die kaputt sind.
Nicht nur einer.
Gar nichts.
Das ist ja der Witz daran.
Du kriegst kaputte Server, die du reparieren kannst.
So eine Webseite um seine Admin Skills zu verbessern.
Da sind richtig schwierige Aufgaben teilweise dabei.
Aber ich warte jetzt erstmal, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist und ich mal eine Melone
gefuttert habe, dann geht's los.
Was ist das?
Da hängt ja noch so ein Kern drin.
Geh weg.
Ich bin Senior. Ich bin 42.
Da geht man schon als Senior durch.
Streng genommen bin ich gar kein Linux-Engineer mehr.
Die haben meinen Job umbenannt.
ich bin jetzt senior site reliability engineer warum weiß ich nicht weil ich besser anhören
So, ich hole mir mal kurz noch eine Flasche Wasser.
Bin gleich wieder am Start.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Das ist echt anstrengend bei der Temperatur.
45 Minuten durch den Wald rennen.
Ich habe noch meine Fitnessuhr an.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was ich jetzt für einen Puls habe.
Also jetzt nach dem Treppe hochrennen habe ich 97 gerade.
Aber ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen sitzen.
Ich habe bestimmt einen Puls von über 70 noch.
das habe ich immer so ein paar Stunden
nachdem ich
renn war
7 und jetzt geht es wieder hoch weil ich am labern bin
76, 75
aber das ist ja alles okay
also man darf ein Puls zwischen 60 und 90 haben, wenn man viel Sport macht auch weniger
das war ein tägliches Vorschlagding von der Garmin Uhr
zur millionen stellt gleich erledigt
ja und starten wir mal
Eine Linux-Kiste
Wo sind wir das letzte Mal stehen geblieben?
Ich glaube, wir haben so gut wie alle Medium-Aufgaben durch, glaube ich
Wir gucken uns das gleich mal an
Ich logge mich gleich mal ein
Gucken wir mal
Aber erstmal muss ich die Linux-Kiste überhaupt starten
Also der Mini-PC hat sich echt gelohnt
Das Ding ist klein, steht überhaupt nicht im Weg. Das ist quasi so, das ist wirklich nur so handgroß das Ding, also von der Fläche.
Aber dafür mit 8-Kern-CPU und einer halbwegs gescheiten Grafikkarte.
Ich meine nicht zum Spielen oder so, aber für Desktop-Kram schon okay.
Und der ist ja auch schon ein paar Jahre alt, da gibt es mittlerweile noch bessere.
Logitech
Was?
Close
Close Device Recommendation
Was?
Jetzt geh mal nicht auf den Sack
Das ist doch keine Device Recommendation
Ich soll die MW4 Beta spielen
Das ist Belästigung im Logitech-Treiber mit irgendeinem Werbungskram.
Jeterino starten.
Terminal starten.
Browser starten.
Und ganz wichtig, jetzt nochmal gucken.
Wir haben ja erst heute Morgen geupdatet.
Wie sieht es jetzt aus?
Natürlich gibt es wieder neue Updates.
Arch, by the way.
Wo kämen wir denn dahin
Wenn ich 3 Stunden den Rechner aus habe
Und dass es keine neuen Updates gebe
Also ich finde das geht eigentlich
Das geht gar nicht
So Jeterino können wir updaten
Jetbrains Toolbox können wir updaten
WL Clipboard
Okay kommen wir updaten das alles
WL Clipboard Git
wir gucken aber kurz reinig dass wir nicht dass wir supply chain attack werden
keine ahnung vielleicht werden so bleibt jetzt bleibt schädigt muss man heutzutage
sich fürchten davor allen wegen dass man so bleibt hat wird
zack zack private windows servers so ich muss mich einloggen chat ihr müsst weg gucken
moment habe ich über einen moment habe ich auch ein passwort stellt hier sekunde
Ähm
Habe ich mein Passwort hier
Ja, habe ich
Auch nochmal Glück gehabt
Ah
Ich habe so heftig durchst immer
Wenn ich eine Stunde oder so
45 Minuten, Stunde gerannt bin
Da saufe ich immer bestimmt 3 Liter Wasser oder so die nächsten paar Stunden weg.
Aber laut meiner Garmin-Uhr habe ich auch fast für einen Liter rausgeschwitzt.
Ich meine, das ist nicht ganz so krass warm.
Und es sind nur 33 Grad gewesen.
Gestern war zumindest an dem Temperaturfühler im Auto 43 Grad.
Das ist schon heftig.
Okay, Login.
Chat, jetzt müsst ihr kurz weggucken.
Augen zu, okay.
ob ich hoffe ich vertippe ich jetzt nicht
Und, habe ich vertippt?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht vertippt.
Exzellent.
So, das haben wir alles schon erledigt.
Mittlere Aufgaben sind wir fast alle durch.
Bleiben noch ein paar schwere Aufgaben.
Gucken wir uns das an.
Ich werde nochmal ganz kurz zeigen, um was es hier geht.
Nur exemplarisch, man hat hier insgesamt, glaube ich, um die 100 Szenarien mittlerweile.
Jedes Szenario, also die mit Häkchen haben wir schon gemacht, die ohne Häkchen nicht.
Jedes Szenario hat einen mehr oder weniger kaputten Linux-Server.
Und das ist ein echter kaputter Linux-Server.
Also das ist eine VM bei Amazon, die halt kaputt professioniert ist.
und das Ziel ist, dass man den Fehler
fixt und dann gibt es da so ein kleines Checkscript,
was man laufen lassen kann, was dann dann sagt,
ob man den Server gefixt hat oder nicht.
Und ich kann euch sagen, die Dinger
sind teilweise echt nicht ohne.
Was? Wie kommst du da drauf?
Ich bin wubblos, Mann.
Max FPS Modcheck.
Aber du hast mich enttarnt.
Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Also lass mal kurz gucken hier.
Sorry, falls es hier die falsche Stelle ist, sowas zu fragen.
Aber vielleicht hast du einen Rat für mich.
Ich bin noch recht neu in den ganzen Informatik-Kurs-Sachen, was so das Berufliche angeht und so weiter.
Ich habe nur das Problem, dass ich von Kollegen und so weiter nichts wirklich beigebracht bekomme und sozusagen links liegen gelassen werde.
Hast du Tipps? Eventuell Tipps, wo ich mich vielleicht selbstständig weiterbilden kann oder sonst was?
Ja, habe ich, gibt jede Menge Sachen. Woher kommt ein Abo-Bubblos? Einmal Face-Roll über die Tastatur.
Ich habe nur gerade Puls gecheckt.
70 habe ich jetzt.
70, 71.
Also scheint sich langsam wieder einzupendeln nach der Sportrunde.
Tja.
Da hast du aber lange keine Videos mehr von mir.
Okay, ich gebe zu, es gab auch lange keine Videos mehr.
Aber ich habe doch schon damals Videos gemacht über Fachinformatikerausbildung.
Und ab und zu ein paar Sicherheitslücken, die es unter Linux gab und sowas.
Das mache ich doch schon jahrelang.
Also, ja, aber ich habe da ein paar Tipps für dich.
Also, ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist,
mal in dich zu gehen, also falls du schon so weit bist, ja, mal in dich zu gehen, was dich interessiert.
Und wenn du noch gar keine Ahnung hast, dann mal ein bisschen rumgucken, was dich interessieren könnte.
Also das erste ist erstmal rauszufinden, was für ein Gebiet dich interessiert.
Ja, es gibt ja tausende Gebiete, ja, es gibt Windows, Linux, Microcontroller, Cloud-Geschichten, Hardware, Netzwerk, es gibt alles.
was interessiert dich denn also was dich wirklich ich meine damit jetzt nicht was du denkst dass
dich interessieren sollte weil du denkst du kannst damit viel kohle verdienen sondern erst
mal was dich persönlich interessiert computer it mäßig also ich kann sagen mich interessiert
microcontroller gebastelt mich interessiert serveranwendungen programmieren mich interessiert
ZLi-Tools programmieren, mich interessiert Linux gebasteln, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert und wo ich wirklich Anfälle kriege, ist, wenn ich mich um Windows kümmern muss.
Aber was ist denn das Erste, was ich überlegen würde? Was ist das Gebiet, was mich persönlich wirklich interessiert?
Und wie gesagt, nicht so nach dem Motto, ich interessiere mich für COBOL und Mainframe, weil ich denke, dass man damit viel Geld verdienen kann, sondern wirklich, was dich persönlich interessiert.
weil dann kannst du gucken was du machst das beste ist wenn du dann was gefunden
hast weil das geht ja so ein bisschen hand in hand wenn du also ich muss das
anders sagen wenn du gebiet hast was sich persönlich interessiert dann fällt
es natürlich auch nicht schwer da energie reinzustecken weil es sich ja
persönlich interessiert umso höher sind natürlich die chancen auch in dem bereich
einen Job zu finden.
Und das verstärkt sich dann gegenseitig selbst.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich
einen Job habe, wo ich 100% nur Sachen
mache, die ich geil finde. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Wenn ich mich wieder mit unserem Ticketsystem rumquälen
muss mit irgendwelchen Regularien,
mit irgendwelchen
Cornshell-Skripts, die 40 Jahre
alt sind und mal unter Solaris entwickelt wurden,
ist das nicht so, als hätte ich auf alles Bock.
Aber auf das meiste habe ich Bock.
Immerhin. Immerhin.
Also sag doch mal, was interessiert
dich denn persönlich?
Ich bin nicht Programmierer.
Ich interessiere mich fürs Programmieren, ja.
Ich war eine Zeit lang
DevOps-Engineer.
Linux-Engineer war ich danach.
Und jetzt bin ich Senior...
Scheiß auf diese Titel davor.
Und jetzt bin ich Site-Reliability-Engineer.
Fragt mich nicht, warum.
Ich habe es mir nicht ausgesucht.
Ich wurde einfach zum Site-Reliability-Engineer.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich zu viel
Cloud-Kubernetes-Jammel-Engineer.
gemacht. Da haben sie gesagt, Max, du bist
jetzt Zeit-Reliability-Engineer.
Ich muss auch mal sagen, meine Sites sind ganz schön
reliable, ja.
Also meine Sites sind deutlich
mehr reliable als GitHub. GitHub
hat aktuell einen Abteil von 93%.
Also GitHub selbst sagt natürlich
GitHub selbst sagt natürlich,
sie haben 99 irgendwas, was aber Blödsinn ist, ja.
Was ist das denn?
Hört sich wichtig an. Ganz ehrlich,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was es
genau bedeuten soll.
Keine Ahnung.
Die haben gesagt, Linux Engineer ist nicht mehr up to date.
Die Leute werden jetzt umbenannt oder dein Job wird umbenannt in Site Reliability Engineer.
So, okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Mach dir mal.
Wayne.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Site Reliability Engineer.
Was macht der denn?
Okay, komm.
Wir lassen uns das jetzt erklären.
Was macht ein Site-Reliability-Engineer?
Also Entwickler bauen das System, SAEs sorgen dafür, dass es auch unter realen Bedingungen stabil läuft.
Ey, das habe ich sogar früher in der Ausbildung gemacht, wo ich ja mal ein richtig oldschool, klassisch Linux-Server-Administrator war.
Ja, also im Prinzip ist es
Eher alles der gleiche Scheiß, nur dass es immer neue
Tolle, advancedere Namen kriegt
Äh, fast gar nicht
Guck mir gleich das an, was du geschrieben hast
Typische Aufgaben, System überwachen
Das habe ich auch schon als Server-Admin in der Ausbildung gemacht
Störung beben, habe ich auch schon als Server-Admin
In der Ausbildung gemacht, automatisieren
Habe ich auch schon
Als Server-Admin in der Ausbildung gemacht
Leute, wir haben schon GitOps und
CI, CD und GDNs gemacht
Wo es dafür noch gar keinen Namen gab.
Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Das habe ich in der Tat noch nicht gemacht als Server-Admin in der Ausbildung damals.
Weil da hat sich für Cloud keiner interessiert.
Gab es noch nicht.
Performance verbessern.
Deployments verbessern.
Root-Course-Analyse.
Reliability messen.
Okay.
Also, bisschen Buzzword-Bingo.
schwer zu sagen, wenn ich mal was skripte oder so, macht das auch Spaß, auch wenn ich gleichzeitig fluche, ja gut, wenn man Sachen lernt, ist das normal, dass man die alles perfekt kann, ansonsten habe ich mal Cyber Security Sachen Spaß gemacht, auf Hack the Box und so weiter, habe ich irgendwie Traffic, ja, gut, dann würde ich sagen, ist das Wichtigste, dass du dir erstmal Gedanken machst, welcher Bereich dir dann Spaß macht, und wenn du das noch nicht weißt,
dass du mal ein bisschen zeug ausprobiert ja hol dir mal ein sp 32 microcontroller bau damit mal
ein bisschen rum installierte der heimer linux in der vm ins holen raspberry pi klatscht man
demian drauf lass mal passen serverdienste bei dir daheim laufen miete dir mal bei hetzen an
den server in der cloud hole mal bei digital aus schon im manager postgres bauer mit terraform was
auch manchmal querbeet zeug um rauszukriegen überhaupt welches gebiet dich interessiert
Ich kann dir nur sagen, meine Ausbildung war auch maximal beschissen
Ich muss sagen, die Ausbildung unterm Strich war super
Aber der Ausbildungsteil in der Ausbildung war beschissen
Ich wurde nicht ausgebildet in der Ausbildung
Es hat mich niemand ausgebildet
Es war keine Ausbildung in dem Sinn
Meine Ausbildung war
Okay, ihr seid jetzt da
Ihr könnt jetzt einfach was machen
Oder ihr macht nix, das juckt uns nicht
Gutluck, Herr Fun
So ungefähr war meine Ausbildung, ja
Mit dem Unterschied
Ich fand es halt spannend und hab was gemacht
Ich weiß noch, deswegen hab ich ja auch immer noch
Ein Herz für Nagios
Von euch
Einer schon einmal die große Ehre gehabt
Eine Nagios-Installation
Beziehungsweise Nagios-Umgebung
Aufzubauen
Aber der alte Nagios
Nagios-Core
Ich habe ja noch ein Herz für Nagios.
Also ich würde jetzt kein Nagios mehr aufbauen.
Das alte gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Ich blicke da mittlerweile auch überhaupt nicht mehr durch, was hier überhaupt abgeht bei Nagios.
Zumindest Nagios ist eine der OG Monitoring Softwares.
Softwaren.
Software.
Und das war eines der ersten Projekte, die ich in der Ausbildung hatte.
Nagios aufbauen.
und da musste ich mir auch überlegen,
Nagios hat so eine Config,
gucken wir mal, ob es da überhaupt noch
Examples für gibt, ja.
Ja, genau, guck, so
konntest du Server anlegen, also,
ey, das war schon, du konntest Nagios mit Code
konfigurieren, bevor es Infrastructure as
Code gab, ja, da wurde
nichts geklickt im Webinterface,
zum Host anlegen und da konntest du Sachen
auch vererben, du konntest quasi
einen Host definen für alle Linux-Server
Das musste ich mir das überlegen. Und was damals ganz grausam war, es gab für Nagios eine Sache, die nannte sich NRPE Client oder sowas. Der Nagios Remote Plugin Executor. Das ist im Prinzip sowas wie der Zabbix Agent oder wie der Prometheus Node Exporter, so ungefähr.
Ja, falls euch das was sagt.
Und das Ding musste ich damals
kompilieren, weil es das nicht offiziell
gab, kompilieren für Suse Enterprise
Linux.
Und da habe ich
gekotzt bei. Aber da habe ich sehr viel
gelernt in der Ausbildung.
Damit.
Deswegen mag ich Nagios.
Ich würde beim besten Willen kein neues Nagios
mehr aufsetzen wollen.
Oder administrieren wollen.
Oder neue einführen wollen.
Aber ich habe ein weiches Herz
für Nagios, weil das in der Ausbildung
mein erstes größeres Projekt war.
Zabbix. Ich habe Zabbix daheim
laufen, in Ermangelung irgendeiner
besseren Alternative für daheim.
Aber ihr kennt meine Meinung
zur Monitoring-Software.
Auf seine Art und Weise ist
alles ziemlich kacke.
Zabbix ist kacke, Nagios ist kacke,
JackMK ist kacke,
Prometheus ist kacke, Grafana ist
kacke. Also die haben alles
ihre Kackseiten.
PRTG ist an sich schon Kacke,
weil es nur unter Windows läuft.
Das habe ich noch nie wirklich ausprobiert.
Ist aber bestimmt auch Kacke.
Es gibt keine wirklich gute Monitoring-Software.
Alles Schrott.
Ja, du kannst
mit denen schon was anfangen, aber
letztendlich, es hat alles immer
irgendwelche Haken,
was es eklig macht.
Uptime-Kuma
auch Schrott.
Monitoring Software ist alles Schrott
Was ist deine Meinung zu CheckMK?
Also, meine Meinung zu CheckMK ist
Vom Ansatz her ist das gar nicht mal so verkehrt
Das Webinterface ist aber halt der größte Shit überhaupt
Und ich hab's euch schon ein paar mal gesagt
CheckMK
Das CheckMK Webinterface
Sieht halt so aus
Das CheckMK Web Interface
Ja, gehört genau sowas hier zum Beispiel
Das CheckMK Web Interface sieht so aus
Als hatten die keinen UI Designer
Das Projekt ist 15 Jahre oder so alt
und das Webinterface
sieht halt einfach aus, als
haben irgendwelche C-Entwickler
auch ein bisschen
Webdesign gemacht
und das habe ich mir nicht nur einfach ausgedacht
es gibt sogar einen Forums-Post von denen
dass die erst seit 2 Jahren einen Webdesigner
haben, also CheckMK
hat seit 15 Jahren keinen Webdesigner gehabt
und genau so sieht dieses scheiß Webinterface aus
an sich ist CheckMK ganz okay
aber das Webinterface
und die Benutzer, das ist der größte
Scheiß überhaupt.
Das angenehmste Webinterface
für mich hat immer noch Grafana.
Dafür hat Grafana ganz viel anderes nicht. Grafana ist
eine reine Lösung zur
Visualisierung, so ein paar Graphen zu bauen,
ein bisschen Dashboards zu bauen. Alles andere kannst du mit Grafana nicht
machen.
Du musst ja erstmal wissen, wo du
und Fuß in die Tür bekommen willst.
Was ist das Problem an den Monitoring-Tools?
Die haben alle, diese Tools
können alle manche Sachen ganz gut.
Aber es gibt kein
Tool, was ich sagen würde,
das kann alles so gut, dass ich
damit zufrieden bin.
Das ist ganz eklig, ja?
Die Kombination,
fangen wir mal an.
Nehmen wir mal zwei klassische
zwei klassische Sachen, ja?
Zabbix.
Wir machen jetzt mal,
machen wir mal Zabbix
versus Prometheus-Grafana, okay?
Also es gibt,
es gibt so ein klassisches Ding,
Zabbix.
Das ist ein bisschen sowas wie Nagios,
bloß vielleicht ein bisschen neuer als Nagios, ja?
Zabbix ist wunderbar
für so klassische Monitoring-Checks, ja?
Du hast einen zentralen Server,
vielleicht auch ein paar Proxys,
aber du hast einen zentralen Server,
Von dem checkst du, ist SSH-Port offen, ist irgendein TCP-Port offen.
Antwortet der Server innerhalb von 300 Millisekunden und sowas in der Richtung.
Dafür ist Zabbix wunderbar.
Die Config mit ihrem komischen XML und sowas, komplett für den Arsch.
Also, Blick Kassau durch.
Aber immerhin hat es ein gescheites Webinterface, dass du die meisten Sachen über das Webinterface machen kannst.
Okay, aber schön ist das Webinterface nicht.
Wo halt Zabbix komplett abkackt ist
Auch wenn es hier auf den ersten Blick
Nicht so aussieht
Ist beispielsweise Visualisierung
Wenn du dieses
Die Zabbix Grafen sind immer noch besser als diese alten Nagios Grafen
Diese
Wie hießen diese Dinger
Diese Grafen die es früher bei Nagios gab
Diese Dinger hier
R
RDB oder
Diese
Dinger
die Dinger hier.
Ähm.
RRD.
RRD. Genau.
Das ist ja wirklich die Ausgeburt der Hölle
gewesen, ja.
Da waren die Zabbix Crafts schon ein bisschen
besser, aber die Grafana Crafts
sind komplett neues
Level. Also Zabbix
sackt schon mal bei Visualisierung
und Zabbix sackt halt
auch bei Metric Collection.
Also wenn du ganz
viel Zeug einsammeln willst,
zu ganz kurzen Intervallen
ist Zabbix halt
wahnsinnig ineffektiv, weil
das alles in der SQL-Datenbank speichert.
Es ist mittlerweile ein bisschen besser
geworden, weil die TimescaleDB
für Postgres mittlerweile
unterstützen. Also sind die immer ganz so schlimm.
Aber der Zabbix-Agent suckt
und generell ist es ziemlich
schwierig, mit Zabbix out of
the box so Sachen zu machen wie
ich habe eine Anwendung und will jetzt da halt
60 Metriken draus einsammeln. So aktive
User, durchschnittliche Antwortzeit,
Garbage Collector Runs.
Das geht, aber es ist ein bisschen eklig.
Mittlerweile geht das in Zabbix ganz brauchbar.
Ich sag ganz brauchbar,
weil Zabbix mittlerweile
die Prometheus-Exporter-Syntax,
also die Prometheus-Exporter-
API unterstützt.
Das heißt, du kannst mit Zabbix
von Prometheus-Exportern Sachen einsammeln
und die sind natürlich deutlich angenehmer
geeignet für Matrix-Collection.
Also Zabbix ist
eigentlich ein richtig gutes, klassisches
monitoring tool wenn es halt um so sachen geht wie ist das aber da oder nicht da oder das höchste der
gefühle was tabx individuell bei servern kann ist halt cpu auslastung ram auslastung disk usage und
sowas ja dass dafür ist habe ich ganz gute muss man ein agent installieren okay aber für alles
andere über überwachung von irgendwelchen cloud ressourcen sei es was wobei ich das ehrlich gesagt
sagen muss habe ich mir lange nicht mehr angeguckt wie gut mittlerweile die kubernetes unterstützung
für die managed kubernetes unterstützung für aws für escher und für google und sowas ist in
tabics keine ahnung vielleicht ist auch ganz gut meine persönliche vermutung ist das sagt immer
noch und das zu customizen ist eine ausgeburt der hölle aus xml dateien so wie das bei tabics
normalerweise so ist.
So.
Und für
langfristige
Metrik
Metrik Collection,
wo du quasi alle 10 Sekunden
einsammelst
von zig Servern
seitenweise Metriken,
da macht Zabbix schnell
Schlappt. Ich will nicht behaupten, dass es
keine krassen Zabbix Experts auf der Welt
gibt, die das irgendwie hinkriegen, aber das
zumindest dafür nicht gedacht das ist nicht die stärke so also für klassische monitoring sachen
so ist das server da ist der dauer ist die festplatte voll inklusive eingebauten lörting
sie auch wichtig ist ja nicht nur wichtig bei einem monitoring tool zu sehen in dem monitoring
tool oho die festplatte wird weil es bald voll sondern muss ja auch ein alert schicken können
die festplatte ist voll diese kombination so ganz das ganz klassische monitoring dashboard
mit blub festplatte läuft voll alert e mail geht raus irgendein chat channel geht raus leute werden
alarmiert dafür ist es gut ja für time series datenbanken oder für für time series metriken
und visualisierung ist habe ich nix doch vergleichen wir das jetzt mal etwas anderen
was auch beliebtes prometheus grafana grafana ist ein reines visualisierungs tool als mit
Du kannst mit Grafana schöne Dashboards bauen, aber auch nicht mehr.
Du kannst so ein halbherziges Alerting, glaube ich, mittlerweile damit machen.
Ich kenne aber niemand, der das macht.
So, das heißt, Grafana brauchst du irgendeinen Datenkollektor.
Grafana alleine kann das nicht.
Grafana kann nur Datensourcen visualisieren.
Dafür muss man sagen, relativ schicke, gucken wir uns mal eine Grafana-Demo an,
dafür relativ schicke Dashboards.
Also die Grafana-Dashboards sind wirklich...
Also wenn ihr mich fragt, so, gibt ja noch ein paar
Konkurrenzprodukte.
Es gibt von InfluxDB, von den InfluxDB-Leuten
gibt es, das heißt glaube ich
ChronoCraft oder so, gibt es so eine
Grafana, so ein Grafana-Abklatsch.
Aber wenn ihr mich fragt,
Grafana ist so für Dashboards echt
so das Nonplusultra.
Das funzt einfach und
taugt, ja.
Also musst du echt sagen, wenn du
Und wenn du das hier mit Zabbix-Grafen vergleichst, ist das hier um Längen besser.
Guck, du kannst hier richtig schön reinzoomen, kannst dir das angucken, kannst sogar Auto-Refresh und sowas einstellen.
Also Grafana ist da wirklich top.
Aber wie gesagt, Grafana ist reine Visualisierung, was man hier auch sieht.
Du kannst damit schöne Dashboards bauen.
Daten sammeln kann Grafana nicht.
Das heißt, du brauchst noch irgendeinen Collector dabei.
Die meisten Leute machen das mit Prometheus.
Prometheus wiederum ist quasi so eine
Time-Series-Datenbank für Metriken
Prometheus ist dafür gedacht
ganz viele Daten
für bestimmte Timestamps
abzuspeichern, sodass du dann
im Nachhinein nachgucken kannst, ey guck mal hier
auf meinem Cluster mit
diesen 20 Pods von der Anwendung
so und so ist da die Auslastung
und die Logins über den Tag hinweg
und sowas, das kannst du wunderbar machen
wo die Kombination bei Prometheus, also wie gesagt, Prometheus ist super für Metriken-Collecting
und für halbwegs langfristiges Speichern von Metriken,
sodass du vor zwei Jahren noch gucken kannst, ey, guck mal, wie war denn hier die Auslastung des Services am 16.08.2023.
Dafür ist Prometheus ganz gut und Kafana zum Visualisieren. Wo Prometheus wiederum schlecht ist, ist klassisches Monitoring. Sowas wie, ist der Server up und down, es gibt ja leider schon drei verschiedene up, down, starti bei Prometheus. Das ist nicht gut.
Also sowas wie, ist der Port offen, ist die Festplatte voll, Alerting und sowas, das ist ganz grausam.
Ja, bei Prometheus gibt es so Hilfsdinger wie den Alert Manager, mit dem kann man das ein bisschen nachbauen.
Aber letztendlich muss einem klar sein, wenn man sich für Prometheus als Hauptmonitoring-Tool entscheidest,
dann ist das, ja, ich weiß, es gibt noch andere Tools, aber du kannst, wenn du es nicht total übertreibst,
kannst du ohne Probleme auch zwei Jahre Metric in Prometheus halten, das geht.
Ja, wenn du nicht hunderttausende Metrix da alle paar Sekunden einsammelst, das geht schon.
Aber der Rest, das ist komplett Selbstmonitoring-Bau.
Prometheus ist nichts anderes wie ein Datenkollektor.
Das heißt, du musst deine Agents auf alle Server verteilen, du musst die Agents konfigurieren, du musst einstellen, was du collecten willst.
Du brauchst eine Visualisierungssoftware.
Alerts musst du selber bauen.
Also Prometheus ist ein Do-It-Yourself-Monitoring.
Du musst dir dein Monitoring selbst bauen.
Weil Prometheus an sich ja kein Monitoring ist.
Prometheus ist ein Datenkollektor.
Kein Monitoring-Tool.
Du kannst das zum Monitoring verwenden, aber das ist kein Monitoring-Tool in Form von Vizabix.
So nach dem Motto, Festplatte über 80% Alert.
Oder schönen Graph bauen.
Das ist es nicht.
Du kannst es visualisieren mit Grafana, du kannst es mit Alert Manager Alerts zusätzlich einbauen.
Das ist aber keine All-in-One-Lösung.
Prometheus collectet einfach nur.
Wo sowohl Zabbix als auch Prometheus dann schon mal komplett...
Also bleiben wir erstmal nochmal bei Prometheus.
Bei Prometheus hast du halt das Problem so Sachen wie Up-Down-Monitoring.
Das ist super krasses Gefrickel.
Also es gibt den Blackbox-Exporter, der ist schon mal eklig zu konfigurieren.
Da brauchst du dann einen extra Host, der die Sachen ausführt, dann gibt es noch irgendeinen Textfile, Kollektor und sowas. Das ist alles machbar, du kannst ja mit Prometheus dein komplett eigenes, customised, auf dich zugeschnittenes Monitoring bauen, aber es ist nichts, was jetzt mal easy zu machen ist.
also das und man merkt auch dass prometheus das streut sich das ist nicht für klassisches ist
der port offen oder down gedacht ja das kannst du damit alles bauen aber es ist nicht schön
prometheus ist dafür gedacht tausende metriken von anwendungen zu sammeln oder eben halten
node exporter zu skraten so was schon einmal sowohl prometheus als auch tabics nicht richtig
können ist wenn wir dann in richtung logs und traces gehen wenn du logs einsammeln willst und
logs analysieren willst oder gar anwendungs traces so dass du über deine anwendungen hindurch
verfolgen kannst wie irgendwelche request laufen und sowas da fällt beides erstmal komplett flach
Da brauchst du wieder was anderes für. Und das ist das, was ich meine. Alle Monitoring-Tools können irgendwas Gutes, aber sind auch auf dem anderen Bein quasi auch ziemlich beschissen. Es gibt kein Monitoring-Tool, wo ich sagen will, kommen wir mal zu anderen Sachen.
so wie sie ab time kuma ist zum beispiel im heimer im heim bereich sehr beliebt ab
time kuma ist super um zu checken ist das service ab oder dauern ist die
webseite erreichbar antworten die webseite oder was hat dann ab dann kummer
für standard für standard checks monitoring ungleich logging aber du
kannst an logs oftmals ziemlich gut erkennen wenn was kaputt ist
Wo steht denn hier, was die für Standardchecks haben?
Keine Ahnung.
Sensors.
Nö.
Ach, Sponsors, nicht Sensors.
Ach, hier, guck mal, hier gibt es eine Demo.
Next.
SQLite.
Jawohl.
So, also hier kannst du dann...
Egal.
Da kannst du dann so Sachen monitoren, wie ist die Webseite ab oder down.
Aber was halt Uptime Kuma schon mal gar nicht hat, ist eine History.
Klar, du kannst alles fragen, was du willst.
So.
Uptime Kuma ist für den Heimbereich super, aber sobald du eine History haben willst...
So ey, sag mal, wie ist denn eigentlich die Entwicklung meines Festplattenplatzes auf dem und dem Server über die letzten drei Monate gewesen?
Geht nicht mit Uptime-Kummer.
Ist einfach nicht dafür gedacht.
Stößt er damit relativ schnell an die Grenzen.
Und das was ich meine, es gibt einfach kein gescheites Monitoring-Tool, wo ich sagen würde, ey, das ist eine richtig geile Kombination aus allem, was man braucht.
und dann auch noch so, dass es sich irgendwie richtig anfühlt.
Das gibt es nicht. Also, kenne ich nicht. Ist mir noch nicht untergekommen.
Ich finde auf ihre Art und Weise alle Monitoring-Tools, die ich bisher gesehen und ausprobiert habe, kacke.
Wenn du in einem mittelständischen Unternehmen ein Monitoring etablieren solltest,
wie würdest du das machen und mit welchen Tools?
Ich würde mir erstmal überlegen, was ich denn hauptsächlich monitoren will. Geht es mir eher darum, dass ich eine All-in-One-Lösung habe, dass ich so klassisches Monitoring machen kann, wie Webseite ist da, Server ist da, Port ist offen, Festplatte ist nicht zu voll und Alerting?
oder geht es mir eher darum, dass ich Metriken von Anwendungen sammeln will?
Da würde ich erstmal prinzipiell dazwischen unterscheiden.
Weil in dem einen ist zum Beispiel so klassische Monitoring-Tools wie CheckMK und Subix gut,
in dem anderen überhaupt nicht.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich finde alles eklig
Also ich finde alles
Irgendwie
Es hat alles seine gute Seiten
Aber auch
Eklige
Ist es ein Datenpornproblem, dass es keine gibt, welche alle verschiedenen Use Cases unterstützt?
Ich denke zum Teil schon, aber das ließe sich ja lösen.
Ich habe das schon oft gesagt, dass ich gerne sowas machen würde.
Das Problem ist aber, dass es ein Projekt ist, das alleine absolut nicht zu stemmen.
Bis sowas gut ist, braucht es Jahre Entwicklung mit einem größeren Team.
Und wie soll ich das machen? Können wir vergessen.
Und ihr kennt meine Motivation, was das Projekte umsetzen angeht.
Ich fange immer motiviert an, dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr nach einem halben Jahr.
Ne, ne, das klappt nicht.
Aber das Problem mit der Datenbank wäre ja durchaus zu lösen.
Also ich denke mal, dass man das mit Postgres bestimmt, wenn man es gescheit macht, irgendwie abfackeln könnte.
Postgres hat ja für alles irgendwelche Erweiterungen.
Oder man muss halt gucken, dass man das splittet.
Aber das wäre bestimmt möglich, ja.
Also, ich sehe es auf der Arbeit.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir CheckMK.
Also CheckMK ist da gesetztes Monitoring-Tool.
Und du musst, wenn du was aufbaust, das ins CheckMK nehmen.
Auch wenn das CheckMK-Monitoring kacke ist.
Und ich betreue ein paar Anwendungen, die auf Kubernetes laufen.
Und ich kann euch sagen, das CheckMK-Kubernetes-Monitoring, es ist maximal useless.
Es ist maximal useless. Ich habe noch nicht eine Sache jemals in diesem Check-MK Kubernetes Monitoring gesehen, was mir was gebracht hätte.
Außer, dass es ab und zu nervt, wenn Google mal Rolling Cluster Update macht oder sowas.
Nichts, das ist komplett useless. Komplett.
Also ich kann euch sagen
Wie in dem einen Service
Unser Monitoring zur Zeit aussieht
Das ist eine Anwendung
Die läuft im Kubernetes Cluster
Und natürlich gibt es da diese Standard Dinger
Wie gesagt es gibt das Standard CheckMK Monitoring
Was aber maximal useless ist
Es gibt diese Standard Geschichten
die Google verschickt, wenn er ein Cluster-Problem hat oder nicht richtig scalen kann oder so.
Ja, das ist an. Dann haben wir noch ein paar Alerts auf irgendwelche Lockmeldungen.
Aber ich habe das so gemacht, ich habe unser Grafana, unser lokales Grafana, mit der Google Cloud verbunden.
Es gibt nämlich ein relativ gutes Google Cloud Plugin für Grafana.
Es kann quasi direkt die Daten in der Google Cloud abfragen und wir haben Managed Prometheus Monitoring bei Google.
Also du kannst, wenn du bei Google ein Kubernetes-Cluster aufbauen lässt, kannst du auch ein Häkchen machen quasi für Managed Prometheus.
Dann hast du so einen Managed Prometheus-Kollektor, der deine Endpunkte scrapen kann im Cluster.
Das ist eigentlich super praktisch, du musst dich nicht selbst um das Prometheus-Hosting kümmern.
Und dann habe ich einfach unseren Grafana mit dem Google, es gibt hier Grafana, Grafana, Google Cloud.
google cloud monitoring data source damit hast du mittlerweile zugriff auch auf die
manager die manager prometheus sachen und da kannst du dir hier mit schöne schöne dashboards
bauen und um die details unserer zumindest von der einen anwendung besser observieren zu können haben
wir ja auch einen eigenen prometheus exporter programmiert der dort als sidecar mitläuft im
kubernetes das ist ein bisschen kleiner service und er fragt lokal die api ab
von von der software und bereitet es auf und stellt als prometheus metriken
bereit ja und da haben wir uns ein schönes dashboard gebaut da gucken wir
dann ab und zu mal rein und gut ist
Richtig.
Okay, ich bin ja nicht...
Dann bin ich ja froh, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin,
der das alles für komplett useless und überflüssig hält.
Das Check-MK-Kubernetes-Monitoring, man.
Was macht eigentlich der?
Ich sollte das...
Ich sollte das Ding echt mal archivieren, oder?
Cannot be installed.
Mon KS, Alter.
Aber Hauptsache, ich hatte es in meiner Bewerbung drin stehen, unter den GitHub-Links.
Habe ich wenigstens ordentliche Comment-Messages gemacht.
Geht so.
Geht so
Na gut
So, jetzt habe ich mich lange genug über Monitoring ausgelassen
Wenn ihr noch Questions habt, könnt ihr loslegen
Ich futter jetzt noch vier Kirschen, die ich hier habe
Und dann geht's los
Und dann muss ich, während wir Setserver machen
Noch irgendwie zwei Sandwich-Maker-Toastbrote futtern
Sandwich Maker eh beste
Schon mal was mit SAP gemacht
Nicht direkt
Ich muss manchmal irgendwelche User bei uns auf der Arbeit
Für SAP beantragen
Ohne wirklich zu wissen was die dann mit diesen Usern machen
Aber direkt mit SAP ne
Ich weiß nur, dass man als SAP-Consultant unnormal viel Geld verdienen kann.
Oder stimmt das nicht, Chat?
Das stimmt, das ist er.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, Chatman, Puls ist wieder runter auf 69.
Anscheinend habe ich meine Laufrunde gut weggesteckt heute.
Obwohl es so warm war.
und anstrengend.
69.
Bald habe ich sogar
6-7-Puls, wobei das ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr
angesagt.
So.
Chat, ihr könnt euch eine Aufgabe aussuchen,
die wir machen wollen. Wir machen jetzt mal eine
schwere Aufgabe, okay?
Ihr könnt euch eine Aufgabe aussuchen von Hart 1 bis 19.
Also außer die, die wir schon gemacht haben.
Dann starte ich die Challenge.
Wir gucken uns das zusammen an.
Und dann schauen wir mal,
Wie gut ich das auf die Reihe kriege
Also, was wollen wir machen?
Exploiting Capabilities
Harbor full of issues
Pull a rabbit from a head
Das haben wir schon mal gemacht
Da kann ich mich auch noch dunkel dran erinnern
Olamar LLM Troubles
Docker Web Container
Can't connect to DB Container
Okay
Ich würde sagen
Dann fangen wir mal von oben nach unten an
Das erste war 16
Das kann sein, dass ich hier
voll versage jetzt
sag ich nur mal dazu
also die Aufgabe
sieht wie folgendermaßen auf
sieht wie folgendermaßen aus, also Level schwer
Typ Hackerman
ich starte das schon mal
also, wir sind eingeloggt
als Admin User, ohne Sudo
Rechte
es gibt ein Secret String in dem File
unter slash root slash flag txt
ich hab keine Permissions
das zu readen
Ein Standard-System-Binary wurde falsch konfiguriert.
That allows it to bypass file permissions.
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Your mission is to find the misconfigured binary and use it to copy the content of root flag txt into the file home admin flag txt.
Na, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob wir das jetzt auf die Reihe kriegen.
Dann wollen wir mal, oder?
SSH.
Yes.
Da sind wir.
Haben wir denn wirklich keine Pseudo-Privileges?
Wir haben keine Pseudo-Privileges.
Es ist auch kein 0815-Passwort.
Haben wir Docker drauf?
Wir haben Docker nicht drauf.
Haben wir Potman drauf?
Potman.
Haben wir auch nicht drauf.
Okay.
Gut.
Gut. Also, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch auf der Kiste liegen?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch auf der Kiste liegen?
Also, Bash-Profile, da wird wahrscheinlich nichts drin.
Pseudo-Admin-Successful?
Das ist eigentlich nicht so wirklich der Fall.
So.
Read me Bash History Agent.
A standard system binary has been
misconfigured with a hidden capability
that allows it to bypass file permissions.
Keine Ahnung, das könnte ja alles sein.
Wo fange ich denn da jetzt am besten an?
Den geht auf unser bin okay
Nein der besser às glaube ich nichts
Also Userbin haben wir hier irgendwas
Ist hier irgendwie irgendwelche komischen
Komischen Flags
Vielleicht gesetzt
Was ist das hier?
War es das vielleicht immer so?
Okay, das ist immer so.
Can't wait.
Ich futter mal kurz nebenbei meinen Sandwich Maker Toastbrot.
Was ich da drauf habe? Salami.
Was ist denn das?
Shedgate, ich weiß nicht was es ist, aber das sieht verdächtig aus
Und Schage
Wie sieht das bei mir aus?
Okay, das soll auf jeden Fall nicht so aussehen
Sass.
Guck mal.
The Shadow.
Ja, stimmt schon mal irgendwas.
Was ist denn?
Was macht denn das denn?
Expiry?
Weiß ich gar nicht, was das war.
Check and enforce Password Expiration Policy.
Also das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich doch nicht so.
Dürfen wir da reingucken?
Dürfen wir vielleicht irgendwelche speziellen
Sudo-Sachen ausführen oder so?
Ja, das darf ich natürlich nicht, ne?
Ja, Permission denied.
Sonst hier irgendwas Verdächtiges?
Was ist das?
Darf ich aber auch nicht.
Gibt es hier irgendwas, was ich überhaupt darf?
Ich darf hier alles Mögliche
readen.
Was ist RMT?
Manipulation Tape Drive.
Ja, ist klar.
Also.
User Local Bin wird es wahrscheinlich nicht wirken.
POMMTAIL gibt es da nur.
USER BIN BIN gibt es nicht.
Okay, also es kann ja eigentlich nur irgendwas
unter USER BIN sein.
Wir haben hier einen SSH-Agent.
Aber das ist ja auch kein Problem eigentlich.
Was haben wir denn?
Pot?
Pott?
Pseudo? Ja.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo ich da ansetzen soll.
Vielleicht mit System-CTL irgendwas?
Ah, ich hab eine Idee.
Könnte das sein?
Was ist das?
Dockertee rootless.sh
Wo kommt denn das her?
What?
Gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass das Docker rootless, äh,
tatsächlich rootless ist.
also ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich ahnung eine idee habe ich etc
system die aber da vielleicht rechnung recht auf dem service zu schreiben
haben wir nicht
oder
Haben wir nicht.
I'm lost right now myself.
I can't teach you.
Also hier habe ich auch keine Rechte.
Ich denke Claude wird schneller sein, weil er die Probleme kennt.
su und sudo
wird auch nicht das problem sein
es ist auch nicht
HWD
Ist anscheinend normal so
Mount
Wahrscheinlich auch
Oder darf ich
Das hier finde ich ein bisschen
Merkwürdig, das habe ich so noch nicht gesehen
Der Rest, keine Ahnung
Boah, ich hab, ich, jetzt hab ich echt keinen Plan
Was, was die hier von mir wollen
Ähm
Könnte man
Was ist denn, rootless-kit?
Linux native
Fake root using user
Namespaces
Okay, keine Ahnung
Hm
Okay, was läuft hier auf der Kiste?
That's that
Also, Pseudo-Dings hier, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
bestimmt auch nicht.
Mount wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Das Einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt, ist
Wir machen jetzt
Wir cheaten jetzt
See anything
Suspicious
Oh Gott
Das ist ja wieder
Okay, das ist klar
Chat-GPT ist einfach wieder am krassen Halluzinieren
Von irgendwelchen Dingern
Meinst du, das hat noch eine Sudo-Schwachstelle?
Wie heißt denn dieses Ding?
Es heißt Madrid
Okay, da kann man sich
Nichts davon
Das können wir nicht machen
Da haben wir vielleicht die Möglichkeit
Irgendwas in den Log-Files zu sehen
Warum?
Was zum Teufel ist eine Bash-Log?
Also quasi was ich ausführe
Ist das Lock?
Bin ja nicht eingeloggt.
Ich kann nichts anderes probieren.
Hm.
Okay, was könnten wir für Capabilities ausnutzen?
Die...
SE-Linux oder irgendwie sowas?
App-Armor...
Ne, was war das?
SE-Linux Check If Enforced.
Wie war das?
ETC.
SE-Linux.
Jetzt geht es nicht gibt es nicht
ist jetzt aber auch nichts drin
ja aber das ist anscheinend ist anscheinend gar nicht installiert was
ist denn das überhaupt für eine Kiste?
Debian.
Also Leute, ich glaube, hier,
Premiere, das ist wirklich die erste Aufregung. Ich habe absolut
keinen plassen Schimmer. Das muss
unter User Bin irgendwas sein. Das muss
100 pro. Hiervon ist
das irgendwas.
Richard, was?
Kuemu.
QEMU?
Können wir damit irgendwas starten und mounten vielleicht?
Ähm.
System CTL.
Da ist ja ein LibWirt oder irgendwie sowas drauf gestartet.
Ne.
Kannst du bitte nochmal die Aufgabe zeigen?
Hier, slash root flag. Wir müssen irgendwie root werden, dass wir da reingucken können.
Leider gibt es keinen Docker, dann wäre das einfach.
Your mission is to find the misconfigured binary and use it to copy the content.
Ähm...
Ist diese Pseudo-Version irgendwie angreifbar?
Aha.
Was ist hier los?
Pseudo-Versions 1.19.14
bis 1.17 verwundbar.
Plattform.
Debian Patches released.
Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich gepatcht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gepatcht.
Genau, es ist ein Binary is Miscon.
Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich drauf getippt, dass es bestimmt irgendwie eine dumme Pseudoregel oder so drin ist.
Dass man das irgendwie ausnutzen kann.
Aber das geht ja natürlich nicht.
Es ist missconfigert.
Was kann denn hier von missconfigert sein?
E ist normal.
E ist normal
Da ist auch nichts
Was könnte da sonst noch
Was könnte hier drinnen liegen
Was man irgendwie aussetzen kann
Ja
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal folgendes
Lasst uns mal kurz
weil wir haben ja nicht mehr so viel Zeit.
Nur 20 Minuten. Wir lassen uns
mal einen Hint geben.
Ach, guck mal da.
Und das Slash,
da hätte ich jetzt im Leben nicht nachgeguckt.
Oh, hier ist der Swap-File.
Was ist denn hier unter MNT?
Soll ich da irgendwas?
Können wir das unter
User Bin machen?
Ja, die üblichen
Verdächtigen, oder?
Ich denke mal, viel anders wird es bei mir lokal auch nicht aussehen.
Oder ich sogar noch ein bisschen mehr habe.
Ja, also das ist anscheinend alles normal.
Wo kann denn hier irgendwas
misconfigert sein noch?
Darf ich die Shadow-Datei lesen?
Tja.
Wonderboy.
Keine Ahnung.
Sieht auch okay aus.
Man kann ETC Pass-WD lesen, bringt mir aber nichts.
Szenario. Was ist das?
Madrid. Okay.
Also ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was das sein könnte.
Ich mache mal Next Queue.
The backdoor relies on Linux capabilities, which are distinct from standard permissions.
Okay, habe ich keine Ahnung. Ich gucke mal.
Ist der Games... Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube schon.
Scan for capabilities?
Okay, da wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen.
Ach du Scheiße. Da wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen.
Okay, ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das bedeutet
Okay
Das heißt
Ich kann das hier starten im Endeffekt
Und
Python Copy File.
Wie macht man das?
Gibt es da vielleicht ein bisschen auch was Neueres?
Import Shuttle.
Und jetzt
kopiere ich
Slash Root.
Falls das einfach so geht.
Oder muss man das irgendwie anfordern?
Jetzt kopiere ich
Slash Root.
Nee.
Slash root flag txt.
Nach, keine Ahnung, tmp.
Easy.
Das ist es.
Ups.
So, und dieser Text soll jetzt...
Your mission is to find...
Haben wir jetzt gefunden.
Copy the content of root flag txt
to home admin flag txt.
Okay.
cp temp.
Okay, Chat.
Seriously, da wäre ich im Leben
nicht drauf gekommen,
mir das mit
Capabilities anzugucken.
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Aber wir haben es rausgefunden.
Check my solution.
Bam, korrekt.
Okay, ich habe aber drei Clues geused.
Das heißt, ich habe eigentlich verkackt.
Wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen, Leute.
Keine Ahnung.
Szenarios.
Next.
Chatgear, was wollen wir jetzt machen?
Komm, jetzt suche ich mir mal eins raus.
Was haben wir denn hier so?
Docker and Kubernetes App not working.
Komm, das machen wir jetzt.
Changing critical files.
Patch and pray.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht.
Ach, da habe ich das letzte Mal nicht rechtzeitig abgeschlossen.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt.
Docker und Kubernetes Web App not working.
also was was ist denn die herausforderung hier es gibt ein kubernetes installats installation
kubernetes manifest sind unter home admin have been applied the objective is to access from
the host web app web server deployed and find what message message it serves in order to pass
zu checken web app docker container should not be run separately outside kubernetes es
ist okay also es gibt es gibt ein web server in den web app der die pläne so nicht startet
es gibt stimmt es gibt ein daten oder sie ausmachen also im prinzip geht es darum
um rauszufinden,
warum der Web-App,
Web-Server,
nicht läuft.
Okay, dann hoffen wir,
dass wir das nicht so verkacken,
wie die letzte Übung.
Machst du nichts beruflich mit Containern?
Doch.
Aber da irgendwelche
Capabilities gucken auf beiden,
wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen.
Yes.
So, haben wir dann...
Root-Rechte haben wir angeblich, ne?
Okay, passt.
Cube CTL, get pods minus A.
Erstmal das Wichtigste checken.
Container creating.
Ich glaube, der ist einfach noch nicht so schnell.
Okay, also.
Hier.
Der ist kaputt.
Können wir uns doch auch gleich schon mal angucken, warum der kaputt ist.
namespace namespace web uns das doch mal an wir machen das ist man describe drauf moment
source was ja auch hier leute hacker hacker man kram cube ctl mit web describe port also
Also was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Ich soll gucken, dass der Web-App-Container wieder läuft.
Dann soll ich einen Curl machen auf den Web-App-Container.
Und gucken, was die Response ist.
Beziehungsweise es reicht, wenn er einfach nur läuft.
Ich soll dafür sorgen, dass der Web-App-Container wieder läuft.
Also, der kackt ab, weil er das Image nicht pullen kann.
Fail to pull image web app.
Fail to pull and unpack, was?
And unpack image.
Docker IO library web app.
Ja gut, Docker IO library web app wird es wahrscheinlich so in der Form auch nicht geben.
Repositors does not exist.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Guck mal. Docker Images.
Docker läuft das gar nicht.
Kann man das wenigstens ausführen?
Achso.
Keine Rechte drauf.
Docker Images.
Ist denn das irgendwie schon gebaut oder so?
Ja, da ist die Web App.
Okay.
Das ist die Web App.
Und da, guck mal, die haben auch hier eine Container Registry.
So, dann schauen wir doch jetzt mal hier rein.
Cube CTL.
Edit.
Deployment.
Web App Deployment.
Mal gucken, was der hier eigentlich macht drin.
Container Port.
Also, von wo?
Warte mal, wo hier?
Achso, hier, Image.
OKS.
Image Web App.
Ja gut, das wird wahrscheinlich so nicht funktionieren.
Da muss
eine lokale Registry...
Das müssen wir gegen eine lokale
Registry umbiegen.
Läuft denn im Cluster
eine Registry?
Nee, das heißt, wir müssen
mit Docker die Registry starten.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Docker PS.
Docker Start. Läuft da noch irgendwas?
Ne.
Aber wir haben hier eine Registry laufen.
Docker
Run.
Warte mal. Upt install Temux.
Erstmal das Wichtigste.
Ah. Temux.
Docker Images.
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Dann füllen wir das doch mal aus.
Ja, da müssen wir wahrscheinlich auch
wegen einem Port. Jetzt gleich noch
Port weiterleiten.
Vielleicht ist irgendwo...
Warte mal. Ja, stimmt. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wir müssen was gucken. Angeblich liegen doch hier alle
Files rum.
Hier.
Namespace, Jammer.
Ah, gut.
Noteport.
Webapp.
8888.
Ja gut, solange ich das Image nicht pullen kann,
ist das erstmal vollkommen wurscht.
Und Deployment-Hammel.
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall...
Da kommen wir nicht drum rum.
Wir müssen Container-Registry starten.
Docker run.
Registry.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich es einfach nur so ausführe.
Docker Images.
Hat der gerade das gepult, oder was?
So, welcher Port?
5001.
Nee, 5000.
Port 5000.
Okay.
Also.
Dann machen wir mal hier Docker run.
Minus, äh, minus.
Nee, nicht minus V.
Äh, minus P.
5000, 5000.
Registry.
Okay.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Curl, Local Host, 5000.
Kunst.
Gut.
Doch, kapiert.
Dann müssen wir jetzt erst einmal das Container-Image, das da, die Web-App, überhaupt in die Registry pushen.
Vorher probieren wir nochmal was anderes aus.
Ich logge mich jetzt einfach zweimal auf der Kiste ein.
Und zwar, wir editieren, wir machen nochmal kubectl edit.
Source erst nochmal kubectl completion bash.
kubectl minus n web edit deployment webapp.
das passen wir jetzt erstmal an und zwar auf unsere neue registry gehen wir mal
eine ipv4 wie viele interface habe ich denn hier war mal hier so 5000
geht ne und ja
Okay, das heißt, wir tragen jetzt mal an die Stelle, wo er das pullen soll, ein.
Das da, Port 5000.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das so die richtige Syntax ist.
ATTP, muss man das da vorschreiben?
Was?
Warum ist das jetzt kaputt gegangen?
Ey, hallo?
What the fuck?
Warum ist das hier so broken gerade?
Ist bestimmt nur ein Crap-Wim installiert.
Hä?
Okay, Images.
Duster 5000.
Slash.
What the fuck?
Fuck, was ist das Problem an dem Edit hier?
5000 slash...
X.
Okay.
Cube CTL.
Describe.
App.
Äh.
Warum läuft denn jetzt auf einmal so viel?
Terminating, Terminating.
Error Image Pull.
Ah, Moment.
Wie viele Replikas?
Eins?
Warum laufen da überhaupt zwei Container?
Ah, stimmt.
Das musst du per HTTPS machen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das geht.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich will aber mal gucken,
ob er pullt davon.
Ey, das ist ja Wahnsinn.
dieses Ding, wie das hier nicht funktioniert?
Da bin ich mir mit der Syntax nicht sicher.
HTTP Doppel.
Jetpods.
Invalid Image Name.
Okay.
Kann man
pull from
HTTP Registry
Urbanitas? Geht das?
Insecure Registry.
Okay.
Das heißt, so ohne weiteres geht das schon mal nicht.
Dann lass uns mal checken.
Wenn ich jetzt hier...
Kann ich jetzt sagen, Docker pull?
Docker.
So, wir haben jetzt hier eine Registry laufen.
Aber die ist ja nicht erreichbar.
Die ist nicht über HTTPS irgendwie erreichbar, ne?
Ja, das geht ja nicht.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall erstmal irgendwie eine Registry starten, dass das funktioniert.
Oder dem Kubernetes-Cluster irgendwie überreden, dass er...
kann.
Wobei, das ist ja wieder voll
hier da.
High IQ Move.
How to pull images.
You need to add your HTTP
Registry as an insecure registry.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich frage jetzt einfach mal.
Ranscher? What?
Er benutzt doch nicht Ranscher, oder?
Doch, tatsächlich.
WTF?
Er hat sogar Blödsinn.
Äh, Server?
Äh, hier ist...
Äh.
Also das
ist das Funds so schon mal nett.
Ja, ja.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Private Registry Pull.
Ah.
ETC?
Okay, also.
Das muss da rein?
Äh.
Mirrors Registry Endpoint
Ja das brauche ich ja alles nicht
Also es heißt im Endeffekt
Ich kann jetzt
Wenn wir da nochmal curlen
Wenn ich jetzt curl hier auf
Slash V2 dann passiert was
Okay das ist schon mal gut
Das heißt, wir pasten jetzt da sowas hier rein.
Registry.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Die müssen wir dann irgendwie nennen.
Die heißt kegw.
Das ist die IP von der Registry.
Aber HTTP.
Port 5000.
So, erfunden wir das jetzt?
Insecure.
Skip Verify.
Ja, Verification skippen.
Ja, genau, das habe ich gemacht.
Was habe ich gemacht?
Was? Without TLS? Aha.
Ja, dann haben wir es doch richtig.
Dann haben wir es doch richtig gemacht.
Wir brauchen keine Authentifizierung.
Dann müsste das halt so ja eigentlich passen.
So.
Restart.
Wie restartet man das?
Einfach mit System.
CTL.
Okay.
Get Pots.
So. Container Invalid Image Name.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Invalid Image Name ist ja nicht.
Ich weiß.
Edit.
So, und jetzt ist meine Container Registry
nicht das hier, sondern
vermutlich, vermutlich einfach
nur keck W. Oh man, ey,
wie das immer kaputt geht. Das fuckt mich ja mal
mega ab.
Keck W müsste es eigentlich jetzt nur noch sein.
So, ha?
Error Image Pull.
Okay, und warum?
Describe.
Weil?
Warum geht er zu Docker I.O.?
Ey, das ist aber falsch.
Okay, wie macht man das jetzt hier richtig?
Das ist der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Wir brauchen eine lokale Registry.
Ah, ich kann das nicht einfach
KekW nennen.
Moment, Docker IO?
What?
Ist das der Default Registry, die ich hier überschreibe, oder was?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
Ich soll das einfach Docker IO nennen?
Seriously?
Okay.
Das soll jetzt was bringen.
Restart.
Gucken wir mal.
Get Pots minus A.
Okay, describe.
Ah ja, jetzt habe ich immer noch den Mist drin, der steht.
Aber okay, okay, der macht ja immerhin Dinger.
Dankeschön, Fiverrex, für den Sub.
Okay, jetzt polen wir einfach nur Web-App.
Jetzt müsst ihr das ja eigentlich checken.
Guck mal.
Okay, der kackt immer noch ab.
Was hat denn er jetzt für Probleme?
Ich glaube, der nimmt meine Registry nicht, oder?
Fail to pull image.
Ach so, ja, jetzt ist das Image schon nicht gepullt.
Okay, jetzt ist das Image ja noch nicht da.
So, das heißt, jetzt müssen wir erstmal das Image noch pushen.
Docker.
Oh man, wie war das?
Tag?
Oh man, wie war das jetzt nochmal?
Docker Tag.
Ob ich das aus dem Kopf hinkriege?
Registry.
5000.
War das so?
Docker Images.
Docker Push.
5000.
Moment.
Moment, Moment.
Jetzt habe ich etwas verkehrt gemacht.
Slash.
Ich will nicht Registry taggen.
Ich kack, Noob.
Ich will Web App taggen.
Web App Latest soll getaggt werden als Web App Latest.
So, Push.
Web App Latest.
docker push to http
in secure okay
es ist ja richtig eklig ist hier
etc docker die man jason in secure registries und das check doch jetzt ja post
aha
port 5000
ok, einfach so wird das wahrscheinlich nicht gehen
System
CTL Restart Docker
ich kack nur, jetzt muss ich hier oben natürlich nochmal neu starten
aha
Okay, Image ist gepusht.
Und jetzt funzt hoffentlich der Kubernetes-Container, Alter.
Cube CTL.
Wie war dieser Trick nochmal?
Ah.
Rollout.
Restart.
Deployment.
Error Image Pull.
What? Warum?
Willst du mich rollen, Alter?
Was ist hier los?
Warum kackt das immer noch ab?
Image Pull.
Aber das ist das Falsche.
Was hat er denn für Probleme?
Okay, wir machen das nochmal anders.
Sekunde, wir machen das nochmal anders.
Wir machen das so, wie wir das vorher gemacht haben.
Regis, wie war das?
Anno, Tag, Latest.
Das ist ja Blödsinn. Den gibt es.
Ja, ich hab dem ja gesagt,
Docker.io ist eigentlich jetzt meine Registry.
dann machen wir noch was anderes registry.kegw.local okay
kegw.local
So, dann machen wir hier nochmal ein Edit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Karl...
Haben die ein Registry dabei?
Embedded Registry. Aha.
Okay, anscheinend schon.
Keine Ahnung.
Image Web App.
So.
Kq.local.
Slash.
Ne.
Habe ich Kq.local gemacht?
Ich glaube schon.
Ah.
Das sieht doch schon viel besser aus.
Leute.
Es funzt.
Der Pod läuft
Da ist er
Wir haben es hingekriegt
Cube CTL
Minus N
Logs, gucken wir da mal rein
Äh, warum
Moment, warum laufen da immer noch
Zwei?
Ach, der Terminated immer noch
Cube CTL, Delete
Minus N
Okay
Wird
Wir deleten den mal
Was auch immer das Ding da für
Ich kenn das
Bin Kommando 2 ein Fan
Aber mit K9S
Bin ich nicht wirklich warm geworden
Okay, der mag wieder nicht
Was aber nicht schlimm ist
Der kann da ruhig, das kann durchaus an einem Finalizer liegen
Das ist aber nicht schlimm
Ich habe jetzt hier ein neues Deployment
Laufen, das funzt
Wir haben ein Traffic laufen
Hier, so
CubeCTL
Wir gucken jetzt Logs uns an
Äh, was ist denn das Richtige hier?
This is a deployment web server.
Do not use in production.
Wen juckt's?
Äh, warum läuft das überhaupt auf irgendwelche
Get pods?
Minus O, white.
Ah, tatsächlich.
Okay.
Curl, local, äh, Quatsch, nicht localhost.
Curl.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir haben's, ich glaube, wir haben's geschafft.
Ich glaube, wir haben es geschafft.
Oh, incorrect.
Warum?
Äh.
Local Host.
Local Host sollen wir...
Soll das...
Okay.
Aber warum Local Host?
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Na ja, gut, Mann.
Ich meine, wir können Cube CTL
fortformen und einfach machen.
Äh.
Minus.
Einfach so, glaube ich, gell?
Einfach so?
Haha!
Tjetke!
Wir haben es geschafft!
Easy!
Way too easy, Leute
Man muss aber mal echt dazu sagen
Das hat jetzt mit der Realität
Relativ wenig zu tun gehabt, ne
Das ist hardcore gefrickelt gewesen
Mit dieser lokalen Registry
Lasst uns mal gucken
Jetzt nachdem wir es gelöst haben
Ob wir es denn richtig gelöst haben
Was ist der Sinn davon?
Ich frage mich doch nicht, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht
Wir gucken mal, ob wir es richtig gelöst haben.
Check Clue.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das...
Wissen wir?
Das haben wir nicht gemacht.
Das haben wir festgestellt.
Create a registry and push the web image to its...
Image.
Run, Docker, P...
Ja, sowas in der Richtung haben wir auch gemacht.
Das haben wir auch gemacht.
Docker Push haben wir auch gemacht.
Ja, so ähnlich.
Wir haben es so ähnlich
haben wir es gelöst.
So ähnlich.
Wie das, was hier steht.
Aber es geht ja darum, dass es funktioniert.
Nicht, dass man es exakt so gelöst hat, wie die sich das vorgestellt haben.
Wie gesagt, realistisch war das Ding jetzt...
Realistisch ist das Szenario nicht möglich gewesen.
Gar nicht.
Das ist super abartiges Gefrickel gewesen.
Aber, äh, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Es hat funktioniert.
By the way, Leute, wenn euch der Stream gefällt...
Katze.
Äh.
Fuck.
Was, was auch immer.
Ja, Leute, by the way, wenn euch der Stream gefällt, würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn ihr mir ein Follow dalassen könntet.
Weil grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen, sind immer äußerst motivierend.
Ich freue mich über jeden Follow.
Natürlich auch über jeden Sub.
Aber Sub muss er nicht sein.
Follower würde mich wirklich freuen.
Dann seid ihr das nächste Mal wieder mit am Start.
So, wir sind aber noch nicht fertig für heute, ne?
Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt, wir gehen jetzt off oder so.
So, was machen wir denn als nächstes?
Wollen wir mal ein easy, wollen wir mal eine easy Aufgabe machen?
Dass wir die irgendwann auch mal fertig kriegen.
Port already in use.
Gucken wir mal, wie easy die easy Aufgabe ist.
Chat ist eine easy Aufgabe.
Das ist natürlich unter meinem Level als Senior High IQ Win bis Sec DevOps Engineer.
Die darf der Chat jetzt lösen.
Chat, ihr sagt mir jetzt, was ich machen soll.
Chat, Place, Set Servers machen wir jetzt.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Erstmal muss das Szenario gestartet werden.
Also was ist denn überhaupt das?
There is an application that needs to run successfully, but it currently fails.
Fix the environment so that the binary can run without errors,
without changing the binary itself and without breaking the web app served on port 80.
Okay.
Chat, auf geht's.
Ich mache das jetzt von oben nach unten, was ihr vorschlagt.
Also.
Ist das überhaupt drauf?
Ja.
Pulben.
Grab.
Grab was?
Geht schon mal nicht.
Chat.
Schon.
Schon fail.
Grab Port.
Welcher Port?
80.
Oder was?
Also das soll ich machen.
Okay.
So.
Weiter.
Man könnte auch sagen, wir gucken mal eine Runde
Netstat, so die Oldschool-Variante.
Guck mal, was da auf
8000 läuft. 80 ist es nicht.
8000 ist anscheinend das
Problem, oder?
Egal, ich lese mir das gar nicht durch.
Der Chat. Der Chat darf das jetzt lösen.
Chat, ich bin jetzt
einfach ganz drum. Ich mache jetzt, was ihr sagt.
Okay.
LS Off I80.
Geht nicht.
Machst du das öfters?
Ja.
Ich hab das vor Jahren schon mal gemacht.
Da gab es bei weitem noch nicht so viele Szenarien.
Und jetzt machen wir das nochmal.
Alle Szenarien durch. Und immer wenn es neue Szenarien
gibt, machen wir die neuen Szenarien.
RM
minus RF Slash.
Oh Mist, geht nicht.
Lass mal das Binary laufen.
Okay.
8000 already in use
minus minus help
und jetzt
chat gis
stelle euch vor jetzt steht der chef hinter euch
Und der Chef fragt euch und chat.
Wisst ihr schon, was das Problem ist?
Was meint ihr denn, wie lang es dauert, das zu beheben?
PS AUX, Grab, 873.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Ich bin nur Remote Hands für euch gerade.
Kill? Gleich Kill.
Minus 9. Bam.
8, 7, 3. Okay.
Hab ich.
Bam.
Cook ist auch weg.
Und das ging ja vorher schon nicht.
Guck mal, Netz-Set nochmal.
Aber Chat.
Da ist es wieder.
Curl.
Curl, Local, Host, 80.
Hello, Set-Servers.
Also da scheint irgendwas zu laufen, was das immer wieder startet.
CronTab. Okay.
CronTab minus E.
Gibt's nicht.
System CTL.
Okay. Und was?
Status.
Ganz schön viel.
Okay, Chat.
Das dauert mir zu lang.
Ich guck mir das jetzt erst mal selbst an.
Also, wir haben sofort 8000
irgendein Python-Ding, glaube ich.
Haben wir denn Root-Access überhaupt?
Root haben wir.
Was läuft denn hier?
User
Moment mal
Monk HW
So, das hat das letzte Mal dann ausgereicht
Okay, hat es jetzt ausgereicht
Jetzt läuft es nicht mehr
Okay, Standalone
Okay
Ja, war das jetzt schon, oder was?
Ne?
Running, Standalone, Prince
Okay, Curl
Oh
Aha
Was ist da los?
Guck mal da
Jetzt ist es kaputt
Wait a minute.
ETC Nginx.
Sites enabled.
Bergen.
Geht auf... Ah, das müssen wir umstellen.
Ne, ne, das Standalone...
Das Standalone macht ja gar nichts.
Ne, ne, wir müssen das Python-Programm nochmal neu starten.
Hier, das Ding.
Das müssen wir nochmal neu starten.
Machen wir einfach eine Temux-Session auf, Keckwi.
Temux-Session auf.
Das starten wir jetzt.
Das starten wir jetzt auf Port 8001.
Äh...
Jetzt habe ich es vorhin abgeschossen.
Wo lag das Ganze denn überhaupt?
Admin.
Ah.
Home Admin.
Wo liegt denn das?
Find.
Name.
Manage.
Pi.
Ah, hier.
Guck.
Da.
Django App.
ok tmux
8001 you have to an apply my creations yahoo fucking chaos
So, Wim, ETC,
Nginx, Sites,
Enabled, Bergen,
auf 8001,
System,
CTL, Restart,
Nginx,
so,
okay, Curl,
Ford 80, geht,
Standalone, geht auch,
Check my solution,
äh,
Hä?
Äh.
Moment.
Chat, es ist doch alles erfüllt.
Es ist doch alles erfüllt.
Puh.
Äh.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Was ist das Problem?
Ist doch alles richtig, wie es sein soll.
Der guckt, dass es ein System D Service ist.
Ja, davon ist ja nirgendswo die Rede, dass das so sein muss.
Davon ist nirgendswo die Rede.
Also müssen wir das umstellen.
Aus dem Checkhaus kommentieren.
Okay.
Also.
Das heißt, wir schmeißen das hier weg.
System.
CTL.
Moment, da müssen wir erst noch hier die System D Unit aktualisieren.
Wo könnte das liegen?
System.
Django Web App
Port
System
CTL
Restart Django
Jaja
Bist du eigentlich noch in Hanau unterwegs
Ab und zu
Okay, Funst
Standalone
Funst.
Jetzt ist es okay.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Check my solution.
Jetzt.
Bam.
Chat.
Guck mal, das war eine easy Aufgabe.
Gar nicht so easy für eine easy Aufgabe.
Wäre T-Mux genauso persistent wie ein System D?
Naja.
Expressiv, danke schön für den Sub.
naja
systemd startet einen service ja wieder neu wenn er abkackt und sowas
also
ein systemd service würde ich der sache schon vorziehen aber um das kurz auszuprobieren finde ich das in tmogs viel viel entspannter
GG easy aufgabe
Easy. Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, next.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes?
Also, Easy-Aufgaben haben wir alle.
Wir haben alle Easy-Aufgaben.
Bis das da, das ist keine wirkliche Aufgabe.
Und C-Groups-Problem.
Da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Also, eine Easy-Aufgabe haben wir noch.
Mittlere Aufgabe.
Machen wir eine mittlere Aufgabe.
Nein.
Chat.
Egal was ihr sagt.
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Keine Zertifikatsstelz jetzt.
Kein Zertifikatskram.
Das machen wir nicht.
Between two Cs.
Tarifa.
Können wir machen.
Drei Docker-Containers.
Docker-Compose-Yaml.
Na, dann gucken wir doch mal, was nächstes läuft.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin ein bisschen eingerostet, was HA-Proxy-Config angeht.
Ich hab was richtig cooles mal für die Arbeit gebaut mit der Aproxy.
Und zwar...
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin in so einem Blockchain...
Oh, ich hab meine Pillen noch nicht genommen für heute Abend, Leute.
Zack.
Oh.
Okay.
Passt.
ich habe was richtig cooles gebaut auf der arbeit und zwar ich bin ein so ein projekt wo wir crypto
block chain gedöns machen und wir haben auch ein paar block chain notes für unterschiedliche block
chain selbst im betrieb und wir hatten mal das problem dass diese unterschiedlich schnell war
man not 1 vorne man war noch zwei vorne man war noch drei vorne war war nur zweieinhalb
tag zurück also das war sehr inkonsistent und habe ich eine proxys davor gebaut und der proxys
hatte einen custom health check der es auf den api endpunkt gegangen von dem jeweiligen
block jane haute hat abgefragt die die block id und der traffic wurde auf den not gebalanced der
die höchste Block-ID hatte.
Das hat das Problem komplett umgangen,
dass die Dinger
teilweise so lahm waren. Man hat einen
Loadbalancer davor geschaltet und man ist einfach
immer auf dem aktuellsten Node rausgekommen.
Das war an sich eine richtig gute Idee.
Leider war
denen die Lösung zu teuer dafür.
Weil drei Nodes
brauchen halt auch 3x
10 TB
SSD-Speicher. Und das war
denen zu teuer.
Jetzt sind wir nicht mehr hochverfügbar mit nur noch einem Node.
Und wenn der eine Node lahm ist, haben wir gelitten.
Aber es ist billiger.
Es war denen zu teuer.
Aber ganz im Ernst, Chat, mal Hand aufs Herz.
Eigentlich die richtige Lösung, oder?
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Admin.
Yes.
Also, Docker PS.
Was haben wir denn hier laufen?
Wir haben ein H-Proxy laufen.
Und wir haben einen Nginx laufen auf Port 80, beziehungsweise intern im Container Port 80.
Und das Ganze funzt anscheinend nicht.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Curl, Local Host Port 5000.
Hello there from Nginx.
Äh, ich denke es funktioniert nicht.
Oder ist das Problem, dass es nicht funktioniert, dass er immer auf Nginx 0 rauskommt?
Ist das das Problem?
Wahrscheinlich ist das das Problem.
Okay.
Wenn man das mehrfach ausführt, soll Hello from Engine X 0 und Hello from Engine X 1 kommen.
Also der Engine X, also das funktioniert prinzipiell.
Prinzipiell ist richtig.
Aber Engine X 1 hat keinen Bock, gebalanced zu werden.
Dann gucken wir doch mal in das Docker Compose rein, was der da eigentlich macht.
Wir YAML-Engineeren wieder ein bisschen.
Also im Engine X0 und Engine X1.
Das ist doch schon mal falsch.
Network Frontend, Networks Backend.
Moment, da stimmt doch schon mal irgendwas nicht.
Der HA-Proxy ist im Network Frontend.
und der da ist im Network Backend.
Also muss das schon nochmal
Frontend sein.
So, gucken wir mal.
Docker Compose
zu lange nicht mehr verwendet.
Wie
applyt man die aktuelle
Docker Compose
Config?
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf
nicht.
PS
Docker Compose
Ist das nicht Run gewesen?
Run?
Oder Up?
Ab?
Ach einfach nur Ab ohne Punkt
Ach so
Server Nginx 1 ist down
Reason Layer 4 Connection Problem
Warum hat er ein Problem?
Warum Layer 4 Connected
Connection Problem der, was soll das
So, pass mal auf Leute
Wichtigste Sache jetzt
Demux
Demux ist auf Servern
Oh ne, ich hab keinen Hood Access
Was ist denn hier los
Och ne, na gut, dann machen wir halt einfach
Einen zweiten
Machen wir einfach einen zweiten
SSH auf, auf die Kiste, ist auch okay
Okay, hier oben starten wir mal Docker Compose.
NNX ist down.
Warum, fragt man sich da, ne?
Ist der denn wirklich, ist der denn wirklich down?
Curl, Local, Host, Port 5000.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal in die HA-Proxy-Conf.
HA-Proxy-Conf.
ähm
Bain 5000, default Engine X
Server
Engine X
Check, okay
Der, der HA-Proxy
glaubt nicht
Connection refused
In die Engine X Config gucken
Config Engine X
Ah
Voll 80
Das sieht schon besser aus jetzt, oder?
Bam, Funst
War es das jetzt schon?
Easy
Okay, das war wirklich nicht schwer.
Da war die Easy-Aufgabe schwerer als die mittlere gerade.
Okay, meint ihr, wir schaffen noch eine, Chat?
Chat, meint ihr, eine geht noch?
Eine, komm, eine kriegen wir noch hin.
Mittlere, komm, wir machen noch eine mittlere.
Die gehen meistens relativ, relativ schnell.
Wir machen eine von den neuen.
Okay.
Sucht euch eine aus.
70, 71, 72, 73 oder...
74 73 74 74 74 liegt vorne 74 gott
74.
Run.
Also, wir haben ein
Mon-Agent laufen, der
crasht.
So, System-CTL-Status
ist active. Journal-CTL
sagt keine Errors.
CPU-Memory normal.
Restarting the services fixes it,
but only for a few minutes.
Find out what is actually happening and correct user local bin monagentwatchdog.sh
so it tracks the running process correctly without disabling the watchdog.
Test watchdog is still active and after monagent restart it does not kill restart the newly created worker.
Was? Okay, ich hab kein Plastenschimmer, was Sache ist, aber wir gucken uns einfach mal den Server an.
So.
Wir loggen uns einfach gleich schon mal doppelt drauf ein.
Falls wir es brauchen.
Also.
PS-Aux-Crap.
Mon. Läuft angeblich irgendwas.
Mon-Agent.
Und der
disappeared. Ab und zu mal.
Oder wie?
System-CTL-Status-Mon-Agent.
Ich habe ihn bis jetzt noch nicht...
Ich habe ihn bis jetzt noch nicht
disappearn sehen, ehrlich gesagt.
System CTL.
System D. System...
Was haben wir denn hier Schönes am Start?
Wo ist denn der Service?
Seht ihr den? Ich sehe den nämlich nicht.
Mon Agent.
Ah, wir haben ein MonAgent und ein MonAgent Watchdog Service.
Das ist irgendeine SystemD-Geschichte.
Also, PID-File, Run MonAgent PID, Exec, Restart on Watchdog.
Okay, das ist irgendeine krasse SystemD-Feature, was ich noch nie verwendet habe.
Das ist High-IQ-System-D-Usage hier.
Noch läuft da.
Mon Agent
Watchdog
Pass
Trigger Mon Agent Watchdog
Check when pit file change.
Okay, das ist wirklich High-IQ-System-D-Usage
wieder.
Run MonAgent
MonAgent Pit.
Oh, warte mal. Warte mal.
Jetzt war ich sogar schon beim Stream
so ungenervt hier.
So, und was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Watchdog Service.
User local bin monagentwatchdog.sh
Ist der Service jetzt eigentlich...
Der Service ist immer noch nicht weg.
Wo ist das Problem?
Der vanished doch gar nicht.
Test.
The Watchdog Unit is still active
and after a MonAgent restart
it does not kill restart
the newly started
Worker to Stale Pit Tracking.
Okay, wir müssen mal in dieses Skript reingucken.
Ich weiß nicht, woran die das festmachen,
dass es keep crashing.
Der Service läuft seit...
Na gut.
Seit zwei Minuten.
Okay, ja doch.
Der ist vor zwei Minuten, ist der Server selbst schon länger oben.
Ja, ja.
Okay, der crasht alle zwei Minuten.
Also, lass uns mal hier reingucken.
Ne, ne, ne, das machen wir so nicht.
Wir gucken, ob das auch das Richtige ist.
Hier, User, Local, Bin, Watchdog.
Also, das ist irgendein SystemD-Feature, mit dem ich nicht vertraut bin.
Und SystemD kann ja so viel Zeug.
Hat von euch einer schon mal SystemD Watchdog-Geschichten benutzt?
Cash-Dir, Cash-File, Last-Known-Pit.
So.
If not Cash-File, wenn es das nicht, also wenn es ein Cash-File nicht gibt.
Ja, der checkt alle zwei Minuten
Das ist ja auch okay, dass der alle zwei Minuten checkt
Aber der Check funktioniert nicht
Okay, was ist denn, wenn ich diesen Krempel mal von Hand ausführe?
Nix.
Geil.
Und hier killt er den?
Priester?
What?
Okay, das ist...
Das ganze Ding ist mir zu hoch.
Was machen die da?
Also, vermutlich...
Vermutlich ist das Problem,
dass er hier irgendwo Cash-File liest.
Cash-File. Last known pit.
Cash-Dir. War Cash-Mon...
War Cash...
Updateest du monatlich dein Home Assistant? Ne.
Last known pit.
PS.
Okay, das updatet er aber immer.
Also der Fehler liegt irgendwo hier in diesem komischen Script.
So, und das ist ja irgendwie halt das Problem.
Der killt den Mon-Agent.
Und dann restartet er den Mon-Agent.
Weil die Pit...
Weil die Pit wohl nicht...
Also der denkt...
Der denkt, es ist gecrashed.
So, also das Problem ist wahrscheinlich das hier.
Cat-Cache-File?
Last known Pit?
If Brock?
Cached Pit still alive?
If not Cache File.
Okay, Cache File.
If not Cache File kommt auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht zum Tragen.
Weil das ist immer da.
Also dieser Check ist ja anscheinend wohl das Problem.
Also dass der hier nichts, das erkennt.
Cached Pitch.
Prog?
Cached Pitch Status
Ja, da ist irgendein
Bug in der Logik drin
Und wo kommt
diese Cached
Wo kommt das her?
Hier
Ja, Moment
Das wird nur einmal ausgeführt
beim Starten, das ist doch das Problem, oder?
Ist das nicht das Problem?
Dass das nur ausgeführt wird
beim
beim Starten?
Der muss das aber jedes Mal
ausführen.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal.
Okay, und was ist jetzt mein Check?
Test ist still active.
Okay, System CTL.
Restart.
Mom.
Agent Watchdog.
Und?
Okay.
System CTL restart
mon
agent
Ich meine, das war jetzt hier, ja.
Jetzt müssen wir zwei Minuten warten und gucken, ob das noch abkackt.
Aber ich glaube nicht mehr.
Ich glaube...
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das können wir aber machen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, das war das Problem.
Pit still alive.
Also ich glaube, das war das Problem.
Der hat einfach nur einmal beim Start die Pit aktualisiert.
Und das heißt ja auch, wenn der Prozess mal gestartet wird, hat er nie die Pit aktualisiert.
Und dann denkt er immer, der ist weg.
Ich glaube, das ist schon der Fix gewesen.
Also 18 Uhr sollte da eigentlich neu gestartet werden.
Schauen wir mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, ich habe jetzt einen Puls von 58.
Also ich scheine die Runde heute doch gut weggesteckt zu haben.
Oh, fuck!
der neu gestartet. Warum?
Okay, Chat.
Das müssen wir das nächste Mal nachgucken.
Ich muss jetzt off.
Ihr könnt euch ja schon mal Gedanken machen.
Machen wir das nächste Mal wieder.
Wir machen das das nächste Mal fertig.
Ich muss jetzt off.
Muss rüber.
Ja, ihr könnt euch ja mal Gedanken machen.
Vielleicht fällt euch ja ein, woran es gelegen hat.
Ansonsten, hier, wie Vajana.
Machen wir das nächste Mal weiter.
Wem der Stream gefallen hat, kann jetzt einen Follow da lassen.
Würde mich freuen. Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Schätke.
Wir sehen uns dann.
Morgen oder so.
Wieder.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.